an electric Mount pleasure first ever
conservative is to represent episcopancy
I've worked with marks since May this
year on the spreading some local success
stories
now we've already delivered over 32 000
leaflets and surveys but I'm not slowing
down because I've got big new targets we
need to recruit new campuses with new
deliveries and new activists to spread
Mark's message not just on the Dorset
also as well that's on top of a really
local issue campaigns such as here in
Blackwell with the speeding campaign for
the 8617 and organizing community events
it's tough work but it makes a huge
difference and none of it would be
possible without members like you and
supporters like you my position is
funded entirely through donations so
every member donor and supporter has the
chance to play a massive role because
although it's my job to grow the team
here in bolsover campaign managers and
successful campaigns rely on people
across the country for support
whether that's knocking on doors or
chipping in so I hope that over the next
two years 80 20 candidates and MPS like
Mark Fletcher reliable
[Music]
these welcome chairman of the National
Convention Peter booth
good evening Cheltenham
this is the sixth of our hostings on our
national tour and we're at the halfway
point and we've been so far to Leeds
Exeter card of Eastbourne and Darlington
and for me it's good to be home in the
south west where I live and I actually
get to get to go home this weekend
it's so good to see so many Southwest
friends here tonight and friends from
around the country as well particularly
the southeast and the West Midlands
welcome to the best region in the
country
thank you to you all for attending this
evening because these hustings offer us
the members of the conservative party to
take part in a great exercise of
democracy where we get to choose our new
leader
she or he will be announced on the 5th
of September and as we're the party of
government then we become Prime Minister
very soon afterwards
as he and Dale who moderated many of
these hustings in 2019 said and I quote
I found chairing the hustings a
surprisingly positive experience
the members really put the two
candidates through their paces and asked
some very certain questions
so I ask you tonight to make your
questions searching to make them
succinct and to ask questions and not
make statements one question each please
so that more of the audience have an
opportunity to grill our candidates
both of our candidates have a duty and a
desire to fulfill our 2019 Manifesto
their differences will be about how to
go about that and achieving it in a very
different world from 2019.
post-brexit post-covered in uncertain
times internationally look at the
Ukraine and Taiwan and where our very
Union as a nation is being challenged
so I'm sure tonight that you want to
test our candidates
to seek to establish their strengths and
to see who you think is best capable of
running our great nation
as we're all conservatives here well I
hope because we did have some
headquarters in Eastbourne I know that
you'll be respectful of our two
candidates and keep your questions
positive
as you know our ballot is opened you can
cast your vote online or by post
it's very easy to vote online or you can
choose traditional snail mail
and if you do vote by post then please
remember to put a stamp on your envelope
you should have received your ballot
paper by today and if you haven't then
please contact your constituency
chairman or constituency office who'll
be able to help you
My Hope Is that this evening
will give you more clarity about how to
cast your ballot
I hope that you'll go away enthused and
energized in your commitment to helping
our great party to win the next election
we need your help and support
finally because we're in the southwest I
want to thank our regional chairman
Julian Ellicott for all that you do
Julian it's much appreciated
thank you
and Now ladies and gentlemen without
further Ado let's get on with the show
please welcome chairman of the
conservative party Andrew Stevenson
good evening ladies and gentlemen and
thank you for coming to our sixth of the
Nationwide hostings that we're holding
across the country I'm delighted to be
joined by so many party members tonight
at what is another sellout event an
event that gives you our members the
chance to put your questions directly to
the candidates
all these events are available online
too so welcome to all of you joining us
virtually this evening
since becoming chairman I've been
getting out and about across the country
including visiting seats and campaigning
here in the southwest campaigning with
conservative activists in Toronto and
Falmouth St Ives and today in Cheltenham
seats in this region are Key to Our
Success at the next general election so
it's been great to campaign alongside so
many dedicated party members
we've had an incredibly strong slated
candidate for this leadership election
together the most diverse range of
candidates for any leadership election
in British history
labor would love a female leader but we
could be about to have our third female
prime minister before they've had one
or our first prime minister of Asian
Heritage the second conservative prime
minister from an ethnic minority
background after Benjamin Disraeli
I'm staying neutral in this contest as
are all of our hard-working Party Staff
but I do believe we have two fantastic
candidates
either of them can tackle the big issues
our country is facing taking us forward
together
we are the world's most successful
political party and that is down to our
ideas down to the support of our members
and our record
our prime minister Boris Johnson has
shown that a conservative government can
rise to the challenges of today
getting brexit done delivering the
fastest vaccine rollout in Europe
protecting over 14 million jobs during
the pandemic and leading the world in
supporting Ukraine and standing up to
Putin
that is a truly historic record which
our next leader will build upon with the
support of party members
before we hear from each of our two
candidates let us just remember why a
strong conservative government is so
important
the alternative is a labor-led
government likely in Coalition with the
liberal Democrats and the SMP which was
risk the Integrity of our United Kingdom
labor would have never broken the brexit
deadlock they voted against tax cuts for
low-income families
they voted against additional investment
in our NHS and they voted against
protecting our borders and tackling the
vile people Smugglers
and now they want secure starma to run
our country when he can't even get his
own party on side with a hard-working
majority of British people against
Labor's Union paymasters
with Shadow ministers even joining
picket lines it's very clear that labor
still isn't working
remember when labor last left government
they admitted there was no money left
and no labor government has ever left
office with unemployment lower than when
they came to power that is what is at
stake it is our next leader who will
relentlessly continue to deliver for the
British people leading the way and
standing up for our ideals and our
partners on the world stage uniting the
country and uniting our conservative
party
I know that you all want to hear from
the two candidates to help you decide
who to choose to lead our great party
and our country so with no further Ado
let me hand over to your host here in
Cheltenham this evening
Camilla domini thank you very much
[Applause]
wow it feels a bit like being in a
boxing ring this doesn't it it's lucky
they're not going head-to-head I'd have
to be a referee I think with all the
briefing that's been going on welcome to
Cheltenham I'm sorry if you had a
trouble getting in
um if anyone is currently glued to an
Extinction Rebellion protester let us
know we'll have some extra numbers in
but would you believe this is actually
going to be the biggest hustings that
have been hosted so far in this contest
I think there's 2 000 people here so
thank you very much for making the
effort now obviously we're in a race
course so I feel I have to use a few
racing analogies we're not in the final
furlough are we we're kind of halfway
through there's sort of still a steep
climb and then a kind of free will to
the finish and I know the bookmakers are
saying that this is a one-horse race
they're saying that Liz truss I think is
ahead by two to one members maybe some
of you in here are going to be
disagreeing with that we've had Rishi
sunak haven't we slightly on his high
horse saying that he'd rather lose
than compromise on his own principles so
again we're going to challenge him on
that but generally this is all about you
deciding if you are currently undecided
who should be in the Winner's enclosure
so I'm going to invite you to ask as
punchier questions as you can as
succinctly as you can if we can try and
avoid any repetition that would be good
and it would also be good to hear from
undecided I know a lot of you have got
the kind of lisford leader ready for
Rishi t-shirts on but do put your hand
up if you are genuinely undecided and
there's some burning issue that you want
to ask because obviously that's what
this evening is all about
um and how it's going to work is like
this um if you haven't been to Hastings
before those candidates come on and
they'd address you independently for 10
minutes so I believe Liz is going to
come on first do a 10-minute speech then
rishi's going to come on and do his
10-minute speech and then I'm going to
invite Liz back on the stage have a chat
with her for about 12 to 15 minutes and
open the floor to questions and then
repeat the process with Rishi sudak so
everyone's clear how this works
um well let's get this show on the road
I think is all that's left to say
please welcome Brandon Lewis
good evening it's fantastic to be here
in Cheltenham and I'm here to introduce
Lee's trust for you this evening I first
got to know Liz when we were candidates
together ahead of the 2010 general
election Both of Us Norfolk candidates
what I saw even back then with Liz was
somebody who understood what it took to
win what she needed to do to fight for
and to deliver for her constituents both
in her own seat and across Norfolk where
she helped Chloe Smith in the
by-election as well as up in New York as
well as she came to Great Yarmouth in
2010 and 15 to do her bit for her
colleagues to make sure that we returned
a conservative government because she
knew what we needed to do the work we
all needed to put in to make sure we had
a conservative government for our
country
in 2010 we then became MPS together and
I've seen her consistently fight not
just for her constituents but working
together collegiately to deliver for
people across Norfolk
in 2012 Liz and I both became ministers
at the same time
and again what I've seen consistently in
her time in government across a number
of government departments is somebody
whose Focus has been on delivering
getting things done for the people
across the United Kingdom and across a
range of departments whether it's
delivering in the department of trade on
the phenomenal trade deals that she did
as we've come out of the European Union
or whether it's challenging orthodoxies
where they need to be challenged to do
things better and differently to deliver
better for people across our country Liz
has consistently delivered and most
recently we've seen her as foreign
secretary and as Northern Ireland
secretary is just Side by sideways and
saw how she stood up for people of the
United Kingdom stood up strongly for the
people of Northern Ireland against the
European Union and it's because of his
trust that we have the Northern Ireland
protocol Bill to deal with the issues
that have been left in the Northern
Ireland protocol for us to deal with she
dealt with that it's complicated it's
controversial it's difficult but Liz was
determined to do the right thing give
the difficult message to the EU that we
are going to stand up and she has stood
up for the people of the United Kingdom
she has done that in difficult times as
we've seen standing up to Putin and
being clear with Russia about the
upholence of their invasion in the
Ukraine it's just side by side with our
prime minister and our defense secretary
for the people of Ukraine and even this
week we've seen her standing up and
strong against the pressures we are
seeing and the challenges we are seeing
with China
Liz consistently stands up for the UK
she understands the union of the United
Kingdom and as the next hopefully from
my point of view leader of the
conservative unionist party that's what
I want to see as somebody who will do
that job as a conservative delivering
one of those core principles but we as a
party stand for freedom of speech the
ability to have a low tax high growth
really fast moving economy in this
country Liz can deliver that she wants
to deliver that for the whole of the
United Kingdom and those are the reasons
so no determination and her track record
of getting things done are the reasons
why I am backing these trusts to be our
next leader and the next prime minister
of the United Kingdom thank you
the potential of all the people who make
our country so great to win the next
election we need to deliver deliver and
deliver for the British people
I know that our country's best days lie
ahead
I'm the catheter with a Clear Vision for
the future who can drive change and get
things done
trade secretary are negotiated deals
with allies like Australia Japan
creating opportunities around the world
operative business and as prime minister
I will continue to deliver on the
opportunities of brexit
I will lead a government committed to
core conservative principles low taxes a
firm breakfast spending driving greater
than the economy and giving people the
opportunity to achieve anything they
want to achieve regardless of their
background I will work day and night to
lead the party in the government that
puts more money in your pocket as
secures a better life for you and your
family I've consistently delivered when
I have said I would
and I love our country
I want the best for us all and I'm the
person
foreign
Liz truss
friends ladies and gentlemen it's
fantastic to be here in Cheltenham
now in 1996 at the age of 21 I joined
the conservative party
but I have a dark secret that I want to
share with you tonight
before that I was a member of the
liberal Democrats
look I know I have sinned
but it was a teenage mistake
and all I can say is in my time in the
liberal Democrats I learned all of their
dark secrets and dirty tricks
I learned about the bar charts with the
fake numbers in them
I learned about them telling one thing
to one group of people and one thing to
another group of people
and I learned that they didn't share my
principles a belief in low Taxation and
freedom and the people the ability of
people to shape their own lives and what
I can tell you
is if you select me as your prime
minister I will make sure the liberal
Democrats never come back here again in
Cheltenham
or anywhere else in the west of England
and I will re-establish I will
re-establish the liberal Democrat unit
at cthq to make sure we have a crack
Force stopping that happening
now
I'm not from a traditional conservative
background I grew up in Paisley in
Scotland and Leeds in Yorkshire where I
went to a comprehensive School
and at my school what I saw is I saw
children being let down let down by low
expectations because of their background
let down by the left-wing Leed City
Council who preferred political
correctness to making sure that all
children understood English and maths
are let down by lack of opportunity in
the area
and that's what made me want to go into
politics because I thought it was a huge
waste and I wanted some in our country I
want everybody from all areas to have
the opportunity to succeed I want us to
be an aspiration Nation
but the fact is we do face very
difficult Economic Times
we have the aftermath of covid we have
the war being perpetrated by Vladimir
Putin in Ukraine and we have an energy
crisis
and this comes after two decades of
relatively low growth here in Britain
and my friends I do not think we can
carry on with business as usual
we need to do things differently we need
a bold plan for growth and that is what
I would deliver as your prime minister
first of all
I'd unleash the full potential of brexit
getting all of the EU laws off our
statute books by the end of 2023
doing
today whether it's our procurement rules
whether it's unleashing the tens of
billions of investment that we can when
we get rid of the EU investment rules
which will Turbo Charge indices like
Aerospace which is so important for this
region I will get that done
and what I'll also do is I will lower
taxes
first of all I will reverse the increase
in National Insurance we should never
have done it it was against our
Manifesto commitment we can still afford
to pay for the NHS and social care out
of General Taxation and be able to pay
down our debt starting within three
years
I'd also have a temporary moratorium on
the green energy Levy so that people can
immediately save money on their fuel
bills
and what I'd also do is keep corporation
tax low
because under current plans we are
planning to raise corporation tax to the
same level as France and 10 points High
to Ireland
and I don't think that is a good way to
get our economy going and to be
attracting investment into our country
so I would keep corporation tax law
because fundamentally I'm a conservative
I believe that people should keep more
of their own money and that we should
back people who do the right thing
whether they're business owners they're
self-employed people who go into work
every day
I will legislate to make sure there are
essential Services provided on our
Railways and they can't be disrupted by
militant trade unions
now after I became a member of the
conservative party I was a local
councilor
and one of my jobs as local Council was
sitting on the planning committee
and I'm afraid those are hours of my
life that I will never get back
because every decision we tried to make
we were told we couldn't do it because
of the planning inspector in Bristol or
because of the top down targets from
Whitehall so what I would do is
legislate in the leveling up Bill to
remove those top down targets and to
give local communities decision making
over house building
and what I would also do what I would
also do is make sure we're leveling up
in a conservative way and that includes
rural areas who've lost out on broadband
lost out on mobile phone signal lost out
on roads I would make sure we're funding
our rural areas fairly
I also would back our fantastic farmers
and I think one of the most depressing
sites when you're driving through
England is seeing fields that should be
full of crops or livestock full of solar
panels
I will
I will change the rules to make sure
that farmers don't have to fill in so
many forms but actually can focus their
efforts on producing food and that's
really important at a time we're facing
massive labor feed insecurity issues
and in order to deal with that we need
to continue to stand up to Vladimir
Putin in Ukraine
I'm proud that we were the first country
to send weapons to Ukraine in Europe to
help them in their struggle for freedom
and democracy
and very near here is gchq which came up
with a lot of the intelligence that we
used to expose Vladimir Putin's
appalling plans
I as foreign secretary put the toughest
sanctions regime on Russia of any
country in the world but we cannot be
complacent about our defense and our
security
what we need to do is make sure we're
investing in defense because we Face an
increasing threat that's why I would put
defense funding up to three percent of
GDP
I'll also make sure we tackle the small
boats in the English Channel
I supported pretty Patel in the Rwanda
scheme
and I want to extend that scheme to more
countries and I will also make sure that
British legislators cannot be overruled
by the echr I will legislate for that
I will legislate for that in the British
Bill of Rights
rights I'm determined that we should
stand up for freedom and democracy
around the world but I'm also determined
that we should stand up for it here in
Britain
now I'm a plain talking Yorkshire woman
and I know that a woman is a woman
and I will challenge identity politics I
will stand up for single sex spaces like
domestic violence shelters and I will
make sure that our culture in public
services and in the Civil Service
reflects the views of the vast majority
of people in Britain
and I'll also challenge those who try
and talk our country down who say our
best days are behind us that somehow we
should be ashamed of our history that
somehow we should be cow Towing to other
countries around the world quite the
opposite is true I travel the world and
I know that people have huge respect for
the United Kingdom and what we offer
what we need
is a bit more respect for ourselves and
our values and we need to make sure we
need to make sure
that we don't allow the doommongers to
talk us into another negative cycle
I'm somebody who was prime minister will
deliver for the whole United Kingdom
I've shown that in the jobs I've done
whether it's the dozens of trade deals
that the department of trade that people
said wouldn't be possible
whether it's the Northern Ireland
protocol bill which got a lot of
resistance in right Whitehall but was
the right thing to do to make sure that
we protect the Belfast Good Friday
agreement
and I'm not somebody who takes no for an
answer I keep pushing and I keep pushing
until I get things done and I think
that's what the people of Britain want
to see we had a great Manifesto in 2019
we promised all kinds of fantastic
things but we need to deliver the
doctors and nurses we need to deliver on
our promises on immigration we need to
deliver on our promises on the economy
we need to deliver on unleashing
opportunity right across this country
rural areas urban areas north south east
west we need to deliver on all that and
I am the person that can do that
and I will be able to beat
the declinist kirst armor who is yet
another North London labor leader who
simply doesn't understand the British
people are aspirational that they want
better for their future and they want
better for our country and I will be
able to defeat the liberal Democrats
because we will have a positive vision
for our rural areas we will have a
positive vision for unleashing
opportunity right across Britain and we
will be able to win the general election
in 2024 and deliver right across our
great nation thank you
thank you
okay so that's Liz truss's pitch we're
going to hear from Rishi sunak in just a
moment there's just a few technological
I don't know things that need to go on
in the background so I'm just going to
fill in for a minute by saying
don't forget that we're covering all of
this on the telegraph I have to give the
telegraph a plug not least because my
editor is standing right in front of me
um there's probably
thousands of people now watching this on
the live stream and equally on our
YouTube channel so you can access all of
the hostings because we've got them on
the telegraph website even if you can't
physically be there and without further
Ado I think we're now ready to introduce
please welcome Alex chalk
I'm actually
sorry guys I'm actually not Rishi sunak
and back do you know I'm very pleased
though that um to be saying I'm Alex
truck because it wasn't that long ago
that I knocked on a door in chelt but
the door open this lady goes oh I Know
Who You Are
you are you might be better than your
brother but we don't want David miliband
here either she said and that
unfortunately is a completely true story
now
um I am delighted to be here to be
welcoming you here to Cheltenham and to
be introducing Richardson and to be
giving him my 100 support and in backing
him are not just one of six uh or five
of the six gloucestershire MPS who know
him and have worked alongside him for
many years people who have fought
liberals and labor I also stand with
great conservative thinkers who have
come to Cheltenham to speak at the
literature Festival think William hey
think Daniel Finkelstein to name but two
but also conservative Titans Titans of
our party Nigel Lawson Norman Lamont
Peter Lilly Michael Howard
now we all see enriching
as William Hague so powerfully said a
rare find in British politics a man of
exceptional ability intellect and
emotional intelligence a man who by the
way had the gumption to deliver a
furlough scheme that the IMs said was
the best in the world
and and critically he is a man with
judgment because judgment is going to be
absolutely essential in the coming
months because when it comes to
inflation Rishi gets just how important
it is to defeat it because the truth is
in terms of headwinds on our economy
inflation is a hurricane and three just
marvel at this three of the 18 wards
that I represent in Cheltenham are in
the bottom decile of income per capita
anywhere in our country there are areas
of great deprivation in gloucestershire
and Rishi understands that inflation can
be absolutely devastating because to see
where it can lead us you don't need a
crystal ball you can read the book
history shows us that inflation does
generational damage it can devastate
household incomes it makes getting on
top of government spending far more
difficult it puts downward pressure on
the pound it's why Thatcher called it
Margaret Thatcher called it the biggest
destroyer of all
but I've seen in Rishi someone who wants
to deliver prosperity and financial
stability not just for the sake of it
but for what it can do for our country
for the British people for my
constituents he knows that it's
stability that will catalyze our economy
and deliver the jobs prosperity and
excellent public services that flow from
it and also
it helps us find what Churchill called
the treasure in the heart of every man
and it was on the back of a stable
economy that this government with
Russia's Chancellor delivered in my
constituency alone 30 million pounds for
a new school 40 million pounds for a
brand new hospital Wing which is going
up as we speak 23 million pounds to lay
the groundwork for a cyber Park to the
west of gchq three million pounds from
Advanced Digital Academy in one of
cheltenham's most deprived Wards six
million pounds for state-of-the-art
Diagnostic scanners all these things
have changed lives here in
gloucestershire and will do in the
future because if we secure our economy
all this we can do and more
we can deliver opportunities for our
young people and we can keep vital
National Security organizations like
gchq properly resourced
and I tell you now
as somebody who spends a lot of time
speaking to my constituents out and
about in my Infamous and frankly
repellent hi-vis jacket
there is a candidate who speaks not just
to the party but to the country
a candidate who hi here who I hear on
the streets time and again as recently
as three hours ago who can reach
floating voters and who can save our
country from the misery of a labor lib
Dem SNP stitch up which would literally
tear our country apart a candidate who
can put us in the best position to win
the marginal seats in gloucestershire
like Cheltenham and Stroud a candidate
who can lead this country to a great
future that candidate ladies and
gentlemen that prime minister is Rishi
Suna
foreign
[Music]
traditional conservative values are
clear hard World
patriotism fairness
[Music]
an unshakable belief that we can build a
better future
I've known Rishi for many years now he's
quite simply the most talented
individual I've ever met he's the only
candidate with a credible planner to
tackle inflation he knows that leveling
up
in our Pacific brick on Raw issue I
believe he will be the best prime
minister and help us win more
please welcome Rishi sunai
good evening
good evening everyone thank you for the
warm welcome introduction it is
fantastic to be with you all tonight
thank you for having me now look so I've
been out and about campaigning and
there's one thing I realized people
always ask me about my relationship with
the Prime Minister as you might imagine
there's been a topic of conversation in
this leadership contest but not always
in the way that you might expect
just the other day this lady came to me
and she said you know you and Boris are
very different aren't you I thought yes
let's see where this is going to go she
said she said he looks like he's lost
his hairbrush but you look like your
mum's brushed your hair so in any case
right I am standing here in front of you
tonight in front of this extraordinary
conservative crowd for one very simple
reason and that's because our country
did something
extraordinary for my family it welcomed
them here as immigrants 60 years ago and
allowed them to build a better life now
I was raised with a few simple values
first is that family means everything to
me because the bonds of family are far
greater than anything any government
could ever hope to replicate and we as
conservatives must never ever forget
that
now in my family
there was one thing that we prioritized
above all as the way to forge ahead and
that was hard work
my dad was an NHS GP my mum ran the
local chemist in Southampton where I
grew up and I spent all my time working
in her shop out and about in the
community delivering medicines to people
but also doing her books her accounts
seeing the power of that small business
to provide jobs and opportunity in our
local community
now for my parents there was one thing
that they believed above all else will
be the path to making sure that their
three children had the better future
that they dreamed of and that was simple
and it was education and that's why
today I passionately believe
like all of you I passionately believe
that the best way that we reduce
inequality in society the best way that
we spread opportunity indeed the best
way that we transform people's lives is
to ensure that the birthright of every
child is a world-class education
so that so that in a nutshell are my
values patriotism family hard work
service aspiration and I know as I look
at all of you that those are your values
too and that's because they're
conservative values and that's why I
want to be your leader and PM to put
those values into action to build a
better Britain and just as our country
allowed my family the ability to provide
that for me I want to do the same for
everyone for your children and
grandchildren and make sure they have
those same amazing opportunities too
but
how how will we do that well we need to
do three things firstly we need to
restore Trust
next we need to rebuild the economy
and then we need to reunite our country
now restoring trust for me starts with
honesty and as you can see in this
leadership race I haven't always said
the things that people may want to hear
but I've said the things that people
need to hear because our country faces
real challenges
and I want to be straight with you and
everyone else about what is going to be
required to fix those
but even though that doesn't make my
life easy it is honest and for me that's
what leadership is all about
but we'll also restore trust by
delivering on the things that matter to
people
and that's why I've set out a plan to
start reforming the NHS so that we can
focus Less on how much money we're
always putting into it and more on the
faster better health care that we want
to get out of it
it's
it's what I may want to make sure that
we restore trust with our rural
communities I represent a seat up in
North Yorkshire and I want to make sure
that a government that I leads backs
food security gets the trade deals right
and supports British farming
and we need to spread opportunity
everywhere which is why as Chancellor I
made sure that we funded rural broadband
just around the corner it's wide I
funded the dueling of the a417
at the air balloon roundabout
because leveling up leveling up is not
just about the north it's for everywhere
including right here
but it's also why it's also why I've set
out a radical plan to finally tackle a
legal migration because for too long all
of us have watched on our TV screens
people coming here illegally in boats
and it is wrong and it must stop now we
are a proud compassionate country that
will always welcome those who need our
help welcome people like my family
but they must come here legally and
properly
now when it comes to rebuilding the
economy I don't need to tell all of you
you know what the number one challenge
is it is inflation
and we've seen this story before
inflation is the enemy that makes
everyone poorer it eats into people's
hard-earned savings their pensions it
pushes up mortgage rates
and I will always support those who most
need our help and this autumn and winter
a conservative government that I am
privileged to lead will be proud not
just to cut VAT on energy bills but to
go further to support the most
vulnerable in our society because that's
what a compassionate conservative
governments do
for what I will not do what I will not
do is pursue policies that risk making
inflation far worse and last far longer
especially if those policies seem to
amount to borrowing 50 billion pounds
and putting it on the country's credit
card and asking our kids and our
grandkids to pick up the tab because
that's not right
it's not responsible and it is certainly
not conservative
but we will put taxes and for the first
time in 16 years in this Parliament I
will cut income tax because as a
conservative I want to make sure that
hard work always pays and I won't stop
there just like Nigel Lawson we will go
on cutting income tax for years to come
but we will do that responsibly we will
do it by being tough and efficient with
public spending and we will do it by
growing our economy
and that's why this Autumn I will
radically change how we tax businesses
in this country to reward and
incentivize those businesses that are
doing the right thing but are investing
in expanding their businesses the
businesses that are investing in r d and
Innovation to create the products and
services of the future because in the
modern economy that's how you drive
growth and you know it's happening right
here with Fusion technology with the
Cyber campus that's the kind of economy
we need to build and my tax reforms will
ensure that we deliver it everywhere
but we'll also do it
we'll also do it by taking advantage of
brexit now it does puzzle me because I
keep reading that somehow I'm not
brexity enough in this leadership race I
it does puzzle me because I I do think I
was the one that actually voted and
campaigned for brexit in the first place
there was not enough to do that
we need to make sure that we get the
best out of it that's why as Chancellor
I radically set up new freeports across
the country an idea that I came up with
but right now are attracting jobs and
investment to places that desperately
need it it's why as Chancellor I also
set out radical reforms of all our
financial services regulations scrapping
the EU laws replacing them with new
British ones to make sure that this is
the most dynamic economy in the world
that's what I know how to do my business
experience means I can lead our economy
into the future and seize those
opportunities that are there waiting for
us if we are prepared to be bold and
ambitious about grabbing them
yeah
because in two years time we have to do
something very special
when it comes to reuniting our country
we have to do something that has never
ever been done before we have to make
British political history by winning a
fifth general election in a row
but I believe even though it hasn't been
done working together all of us
with Alex and his high Vis jacket we can
indeed do it
stops
as you know as you know right here in
gloucestershire
it means that we have to appeal to swing
voters everywhere in urban areas and
rural areas in brexit areas and remain
areas in liberal-leaning areas and
labor-leaning areas and I passionately
believe and that evidence supports that
I am the candidate that gives our party
the best opportunity
not just here in gloucestershire but
across the country in beating labor and
the Liberals and ensuring that kirst
armor never walked through the door of
10 Downing Street
so in conclusion in conclusion let me
just say this you saw me as Chancellor
at the beginning of the pandemic acting
boldly radically competently to protect
millions of jobs and businesses and
successfully ensure that our economy
remained resilient in the face of the
biggest economic shock in 300 years
well I promise you that as your prime
minister
I will apply that same
urgency grip and radicalism to every
other aspect of government as we build a
better Britain a Britain where our
children walk safely on the streets at
night a Britain where the NHS is
reformed and efficient and there for us
when we need of Britain where our
schools and apprenticeships are the Envy
of the world in providing opportunity
and of Britain where our economy is the
most dynamic it has ever been with our
businesses investing and innovating
creating jobs and prosperity in every
part of our United Kingdom
but I also promise you this perhaps more
important
I promise you I will give you my all my
everything my heart and my soul every
day
to ensuring that each and every one of
you here tonight
can always feel enormously proud of the
conservative government that I will be
privileged to lead so I humbly ask for
your support not just to be
our next party leader but also the next
prime minister of our great country
thank you
thank you
okay so those are the pictures but we're
obviously going to delve into the detail
and with that in mind I'd like to
welcome Liz truss back onto the stage
[Applause]
hello how are you very well
come and sit down
right let's get into the most burning
issue of the day the week the month the
time and the summer we've had Financial
journalist Martin Lewis warned today
that the cost of living crisis is going
to be as serious and detrimental to
people as the pandemic we've got the
telegraph website warning that energy
bills might hit 5 000 pounds in January
and we've also got Google Trends data
showing that there has been a two
thousand four hundred percent increase
in people Googling the term can't pay my
bills so what exactly are you going to
do to bring energy bills down not in the
future but immediately if you become
Prime Minister
well first of all what we shouldn't be
doing is taking money off people in
taxes and then giving it back to them in
benefits so the first thing we should be
doing is lowering taxes so so and on day
one on day one what I would do is
reverse the National Insurance increase
but also have a temporary moratorium on
the green energy Levy so people are
saving money on their fuel bills and
then second I'm I'm just the second
thing I would do is focus on energy
Supply because this is an energy supply
problem and we need to deal with the
root cause we need to make sure we're
using our reserves in the North Sea and
incentivizing companies to do that we
need to make sure we're fracking in
parts of the country where there is
local support for that taking place
and we need to get on we need to get on
with delivering the small modular
nuclear reactors which we produce here
in Derbyshire and we need to get on with
nuclear power stations as well so we
need to press ahead with all of those
supply issues
as prime minister I will make sure I am
working with the energy companies to get
that Supply on as quickly as possible
and make sure we're dealing with the
issue of high costs now of course we
always need to make sure that we are
helping people and supporting people but
fundamentally the key to being able to
do that is having economic growth and we
are currently forecast to have a
recession we have the highest taxes in
70 years and if we allow a recession to
happen and I think there's a real danger
of us talking ourselves into a recession
at the moment we will be in a much worse
position later this year and next year
so getting economic growth going doing
those post brexit regulatory reforms
keeping taxes low is vitally important
to be able to stabilize the economy so
we are able to do all we can in these
very difficult circumstances okay so I
think people are very clear on your
desire to cut taxes
let's clarify the point you made about
handouts are you for them or against
them
cavilla what I have always said is my
first preference is always to reduce
taxes I do not like the Gordon Brown
style economics where you take money off
people to in taxes and give it back in
benefits and at the moment we're all
paying taxes we're all paying taxes on
the green energy levy on our fuel bills
what I can't do though is I can't write
the Chancellor's budget before I've even
been selected as prime minister and I
think that would be wrong we need to
look I think this is important we need
to look at exactly what the situation is
in September we need to look at what
measures we can take both on taxes and
supply and other measures but what I am
not going to do is announce the results
of that work now because I'm not prime
minister I haven't yet been selected as
prime minister and we know that's your
clear ambition
is my first my first Port of Call is
always reducing taxes because I think
having a money go round where you take
off money and taxes and give it back in
benefits is fundamentally a bad approach
my second Port of Call is dealing with
the supply issue fundamentally the
problem we face is that prices are too
high and if we keep just the answer to
every question is Raising tax we will
choke off economic growth and we will
send ourselves to penury and I think
that's a massive problem although the
ifs has warned today that because of
inflation the government is likely to
lose about 40 percent of its spending so
how can you actually afford tax cuts you
take away the levy and then what happens
to the pay risers that have been
promised to doctors or nurses for
instance well actually the treasury the
treasury is currently making more money
because of inflation out of taxes so
there are various impacts inflation has
on the economy and inflation is
projected to Peak at the end of this
year and is projected to come down it's
been caused by a supply shock and I
think think it's very important that we
keep control of public sector wages that
we don't allow a wage price viral to
take place that we do keep control of
the public finances but the most
important issue we are facing is a
potential recession and what we know is
that when you raise taxes too high you
actually cut off growth and you cut off
revenues so last time we reduced
corporation tax we actually increased
the revenue so it's a false economy
putting up taxes and
it is part of the treasury Orthodoxy to
believe that if you put up taxes you'll
get more money in that isn't necessarily
the case what we often see is growth cut
off people don't want to invest people
don't think Britain is open for business
and I am somebody who has low tax
pro-growth pro-opportunity and I want a
Britain that's open for business I want
to unleash this investment and that is
vitally important to be able to have the
money to afford what we need in the
public services to be able to afford to
cut taxes in future
tax and high borrowing men which is soon
actually just suggested that some of
these tax cuts are going to cost 50
billion pounds and it's going to be put
on the credit card of I suppose our
children and grandchildren is that the
case so my tax cuts and by the way one
of them isn't a tax cut it's not raising
attacks so I support not raising
corporation tax to the same level as
France but those tax changes will cost
30 billion pounds that is Affordable
within our current budget we'll still be
able to pay debt down after three years
but I'm afraid to say the plans of
raising taxes are likely to lead to a
recession and with a recession it'll be
harder to pay the debt down so I simply
don't believe the argument that raising
taxes will actually bring in more
Revenue I think it's a very damaging
thing to do just as we have difficulties
in the global economy and none of our
fellow fellow countries in the G7 are
doing this they're actually cutting
taxes at the moment borrowing isn't sort
of conservative fiscal discipline is it
borrowing and borrowing and borrowing
well the government always borrows money
that's the reality and in fact we are
borrowing less as a percentage of GDP
than Japan than Canada than the United
States
it's going to be expensive to borrow
isn't it but Camilla after major events
and covered was a one in a hundred year
event it doesn't make sense to try and
pay all the money back straight away
raising taxes and choking off growth
that doesn't make sense now after the
second world war we didn't decide we've
got to pay all the debt back immediately
we paid it back over time and I think
we're trying to pay the debt off too
quickly and I think that will be
damaging and I actually think it would
be counterproductive we're already
forecast a recession we know what that
will mean will mean less money coming
into the exchequer and fundamentally you
know people are struggling with their
bills this is why I want to cut the
green energy leffey to help people with
their fuel bills I know small businesses
are struggling with the cost of National
Insurance public services are struggling
you know people who run social care
operations are struggling with the cost
of National Insurance so this is
hobbling people just at a time when we
need to get the economy going and I
think that is very very damaging and
frankly it's Gordon Brown economics we
saw him carry out exactly his own
policies and we've had low growth for
decades now you were a liberal Democrat
remainer you're now a brexiteer are you
just someone who blows in the direction
of the political wind how can people
hear trust in what you're saying isn't
it just politically expedient to
suddenly back leave well
well I left the liberal Democrats when I
was 20 Camilla and I think we all you
know we all make mistakes as teenagers
that we might regret some people drink
too much some people take drugs other
people do other dangerous things I
joined the liberal Democrats but you
know I'm I'm somebody
I I freely admit I freely admit to being
on a political Journey you know my
parents were left-wing my first
political experience was age eight being
taken on a CMD March you know
campaigning to ban the bomb with my mum
and over time I learned to think for
myself
and I I thought I don't agree with that
I I thought the Soviet Union was a you
know
damaging a damaging force in the world
and actually you know I wanted to be on
the side of freedom and democracy and it
my political views have been shaped by a
desire to see people free to live their
own lives and free to get on in life and
you know as I as I mentioned earlier
have those opportunities and that that's
what I think and yet on the subject of
supporting remain which which I did
under David Cameron's leadership I was
pretty equivocal at the time I you know
you can ask David Cameron about this you
know there were lots of discussions at
the time I wasn't sure and I was
concerned about the potential disruption
but once people voted to leave and I saw
there wasn't the disruption and I looked
at the opportunities and I have done
more than most of the cabinet to deliver
the opportunities of brexit whether it's
the trade deals whether it's all about
the protocol Bill and you know frankly I
don't think we have been fast enough at
delivering things like solvency too I
had a round table in the city last week
they told me if we got on with getting
rid of solvency too it would free tens
of billions of pounds that we could see
invested right across Britain you know
in places like the red wall in places
like you know here in the Aerospace
industry in manufacturing industry and
the fact is that hasn't happened because
Whitehall has been too slow and I'm
somebody that will push through
Whitehall and I will get that stuff done
and I will make it happen so maybe
you're kind of conversion on European
issues is a bit like thatchers you're
wearing the [ __ ] bow blouses you're
trying to emulate you today in my outfit
do you know what we're both the navy
blue what is the Thatcher thing is that
are you doing that on purpose dressing
like her acting like her what's all that
about I'm I'm my own person I do think
it is a thing about being a woman in
politics that you always get well some
people are saying why not I said do they
look don't get me wrong I'm a massive
fan of Mrs Thatcher but we live in
different times I I am my own person but
what I noticed and I hope you're going
to ask you know Vichy seen that
yeah
the answer I think it should be I think
it should be part of the Senate and by
the way on cellular panels I'm not
against solar panels per se there are
plenty of commercials
um what would be your plan to restore
water quality in our Rivers
um particularly the river Y which is
severely impacted by agricultural
diffuse pollution
drought in that question as well Liz
because of the problems we've been
having with well water companies
leaching I think it's 2.4 billion liters
of water a day I mean the answer is we
need to be much tougher on water
companies particularly on leaks and also
emitting uh you know nasty pollutants
into rivers and in Norfolk we have some
fantastic chalk streams and they are
very very precious and we need to do all
we can to make sure they're protected so
I would make sure the water companies
are held to account and also
make sure we are dealing with the
effluent that is going into our
waterways and what we still have on our
statute books we still have EU
environment law and what I want to do is
look at the specific flora and fauna in
Britain and how we make sure we protect
um we protect those endangered species
and you know specific natural habitats
like chalk streams here in the United
Kingdom and that is a key law I think we
need to change but at the moment we're
protecting some of the wrong things and
we're not protecting the right things
company Target they were set several
years ago to reduce this wastage by
sixteen one six percent it's not high
enough is it why should our bills go up
if the water companies can't keep the
water in the pipes
I I agree with you and I think the
problem with a lot of utility regulation
is we were one of the first countries to
privatize utilities and we created these
Regulators but over time they have
become less effective at doing the job
and in some cases they're actually not
promoting enough growth and competition
as well so I would review The Regulators
and how they're operating to make sure
they are much more effective but you're
right water is a natural monopoly and
we've got to be tough on the water
companies to do the right thing
the chap here in the blue jacket please
evening Liz what is your definition of
success 90 days having walked through
the gates of number 10.
so what what
I think the crucial issues we face at
the moment you know number one is the
economy and relieving the burden of
people of the cost of living will be
very important I want British businesses
and British people to understand we're
moving in the right direction and the
pressures are being reduced so that's a
very important priority priority two is
getting the economy growing and sending
a real signal to the world and British
business that we're on their side and we
want to open up opportunities and we
want to see new investment and the third
thing we've got to do is really get a
grip of waiting lists in the NHS GPS
appointments and dentist appointment
that is a very very serious issue it's
not good enough at the moment we need to
empower people on the front line so
those would be my first three priorities
but there is a there is a massive list
I'm not denying it's a challenging time
but these are very important priorities
the chat there and with the glasses on
young chap in the white shirt please
um Liz blending hydrogen into the gas
Network could diversify UK energy
supplies giving access to hydrogen Mega
projects around the world trials
undertaken in the UK buy the high deploy
project have already conclusively shown
that domestic gas appliances can operate
safely with up to 20 hydrogen with no
disruption to Consumer reducing
emissions in a conservative way so
industry are ready to get on do this but
they're being held up by uncertainty
from government so if you were elected
as leader npn will you in your first
hundred days make a formal policy
decision to change regulations allow
blending of hydrogen into the network
and let industry get on and Safeguard
our energy security thank you I think I
mean you've just made a fantastic point
I think hydrogen is very important it
does work with natural gas we can use a
lot of the same infrastructure and I
support what you're saying how quickly
would you want to start fracking
well I would want to get on with all you
know we've heard about tidal pal we've
heard about hydrogen I've talked about
small modular reactors there's also more
gas to be exploited in the North Sea
which I think we could get on stream
pretty quickly and I would want to move
as fast as possible with all of those
Solutions because energy security is an
absolutely key priority as well as
keeping prices low for consumers and you
know my view is rather than and this is
the point I'm making about people
talking about subsidizing consumers of
course you know we always need to make
sure that people are able to you know
live in our society that they are able
to get by but we've got to look at the
root cause of what these energy costs
are and why they're being generated and
what we can do to deal with these
supplies and frankly we've been too slow
you know we've been too slow on nuclear
we've been too slow on hydrogen we've
been too slow on these other
Technologies so I would get them going
as soon as possible
um the lady over there um second row in
sorry I'm making I'm making the guys and
the hoodies run around and the
auditorium you're getting your steps up
don't worry
Liz I gather you are you were a remainer
and I have to applaud you the way that I
have seen on the TV racing around the
globe making trade deals or whatever
but I don't seem to read about the trade
deals and whether they're working can
you tell me how many are actually up and
running
totally confirmed and actually giving a
benefit to Britain
so there are there are just over 70 I
think there have been a few more signs
since I left the trade department but
all of those are in place and we were
working right up to the 31st of December
getting those in place to make sure that
businesses could continue to trade and
in some cases could get better deals
than they'd had under the EU but you
know we've today we're sponsored by the
Telegraph and I would love the media to
spend more time talking about trade
deals
the point is that what trade deals is
they open the door for business but then
we need to help businesses actually get
their products into Market we set up the
export support service to help do that
but I would love to see the Press right
right about that rather than about
political Rouse but sometimes this week
because you've had a bit of a go at us
well I had a go at Tom Newton done but
you're asking you're asking much sounds
familiar thank you
[Applause]
um
the lady over there with the spotty
dress I think
thanks and thanks Liz um I think
everybody in this room and conservative
members around the country are going to
come behind whoever is our next leader
and prime minister so my question to you
my question to you this evening is when
it comes to the general election in 2024
whenever it comes what are the three
things about you that are going to make
sure that we bring swing voters along
and hold on to the c31 in 2019 and and
gain in other areas
well
it's first of all I will not have an
election before 2024. I think that's a
very important point and
because we we've got to deliver for
people and that is my number one point
that in 2019 we promised that we would
deliver we promise we'd level up the
country we promise we'd deliver
Broadband we promise we deliver you know
less NHS waiting lists more doctors more
police officers we've got to deliver all
that stuff and we've got to show people
that things are getting better and that
for me is about opening opportunities
getting more investment getting Spades
in the ground getting economic growth
and even I though I'm a pretty fast
mover I appreciate it will take some
time to make that happen so delivery is
the number one point the second point
about me is that I don't make promises I
can't keep and I am a straightforward
person who tells it like it is and I
think that is something that people
across the country appreciate and I've
certainly found that when I'm traveling
around and and talking to people around
the country and the third way that I
will win the next selection is making
sure we're using all of the conservative
team during this leadership race we've
seen some fantastic candidates I'm
delighted that Penny mordant and Tom
tugenhart are now backing my campaign
we've also got Richie kemi you know all
really really competent people and what
I want to see is a less presidential
number 10 and one that really presents a
team of fantastic conservatives who
deliver for people right across the
country so
so the three things I will do
is first of all I will deliver
secondly I will be honest and make sure
people can trust me and thirdly I will
do it as a team okay I'm looking at four
minutes left on the top so let's have
rapid fire questions and answers a man
is so eager for me to pick him now with
the sunglasses on his shirt
there stand up if you will sir and then
they can see you easily here sorry
do you know that it's hotter in
Cheltenham than it's in Florida today
why aren't we staycationing after this
we may as well
yes sir thank you very much Liz lovely
to see you
um you made two points about the
environment which received rapturous
Applause in here and I have to say it's
a conservative voter for nine years
it would receive the absolute opposite
outside green Levy is 150 pound off a
bill that does not touch the side
probably if most people in the room
their bills
and secondly there is a question here
secondly you say you go past Farmers
field and you're horrified to see saying
the panels you'll be even more horrified
in a few years with drought with crop
failure and everything else caused by
the climate emergency cutting green
levees now sends a wrong message to
business and it sends the wrong message
to people yeah do you think that's good
enough
yes so I do not believe
I do not believe we can tax ourselves to
growth and I don't believe we should tax
ourselves to Net Zero I want to achieve
Net Zero but I want to do it in a way
that harnesses Capital that harnesses
investment that harnesses the city of
London to actually invest in the new
technologies so we've heard about these
fantastic ideas like hydrogen Hydro
power but I'm afraid things like the
green energy Levy are yet another
example of us taxing Ordinary People
rather than finding new innovative ways
of bringing businesses in bringing
investment in to solve what our
technological problems and I don't agree
it needs to be that way I was an
environmental activist before it was
fashionable I campaigned in the 1990s to
protect the ozone layer and it was Mrs
Thatcher who signed the Montreal Accord
to protect it but we don't need to
accept the environmental Goods have to
come through left-wing Solutions and
fundamentally I'm about investment and
growth not tax and spent
has been waiting patiently yes sir
please my name is Harry from Southwest
Wiltshire I'm just really
um we make it a priority for
um time to be given so we can push
through the national disability strategy
and that way it would really truly level
um for olives disability
um all around the country and through it
for us uh disability conservatives
that's a key tenant surely you're
blocking it up instead of it being
blocked by Court challenges
um can we get on and make this a key
tenant in the next Parliament
the the answer is yes
I I fully I fully support the strategy
I'm working closely with Chloe Smith in
the uh women inequalities department and
you're absolutely right what we need to
be making sure is that everybody in our
country has those opportunities
including people with disabilities we
need to get on with the strategy and I
can tell you I will make sure it gets
unblocked and it gets implemented thank
you uh the man there in the check shirt
blue and white check shirt please
oh and I'll wait for the microphone
unless you're Brian blessed
yes please that guy there
Liz you've made a great play of your
plans to cut back National Insurance
contributions
which has certainly grabbed the
headlines and maybe that was your
intention
to analyze National Assurance
contributions is complex because of
different levels of contribution
what I have found is that it accounts
for less than seven percent of our
national income
um not very much so the reduction you
promised is very little which you claim
will put money into consumers Pockets
yeah and they will go out and spend
boosting our struggling economy I doubt
that people I doubt that people will use
the extra little bit of net income they
have to pay their heating bills this
winter and will not boost our economy
would you like to comment on that
[Music]
Scrappy
television insurance is first of all we
promise not to raise it in our Manifesto
secondly we didn't need to do it because
we can afford to pay for the NHS
increase out of General Taxation and
third this money is important to people
this is money that we are currently
taking not just from hard-working
families but also from small businesses
also from the public sector who have to
pay those extra National Insurance
contributions and I think it is wrong at
a time when we are facing economic
difficulties to put up taxes I think
it's fundamentally unconservative we
didn't need to do it and it's a drag on
the economy we should be doing all we
can including scrapping or moratorium on
the green energy Levy to save people
money on their bills and to put more
money in people's pockets and I believe
it's their money not our money this is
taxpayers money and too often we seem to
forget that and think it's free money
isn't people work hard to earn that
money and we should take as little off
them as we possibly can
I can see
I can see that our time is up
let's trust thank you very much and good
luck
just to explain to the sound guys I've
had to take this out of my ear because
it was a whistling like I was picking up
I don't know some sort of distant radio
station so without further Ado let's
welcome on to the stage Rishi sunak
foreign
Street and you were running the
government consultation to disabled
toilets A lot's happened in the
preceding years now
um you said yesterday you came up with
remarkable statement that you'd rather
lose than winning a false promise one
bookmaker today has said that Liz is two
to one ahead with the members you've
talked uh very passionately about the
cost of living crisis facing this
country we've got the cbi's Tony danker
saying the government's asleep at the
wheel there's a vacuum of power why not
just step aside if she looks like she's
going to win and for the benefit of the
company comes country
[Applause]
for the simple reason that I'm fighting
for what I believe is right for our
country and
but then why do you think Chris Skidmore
has defected from you to trust them well
look everyone's I've got a lot of
respect for all my colleagues I'm still
very proud of the fact that in the
Parliamentary stage of this I led in
every single round I topped the ballot
in every single round I have the most
support from members of parliament and
actually it's not just numbers if you
look at it it's a breadth of support
that I'm proud about it's from
parliamentary colleague from across the
Spectrum people who voted for brexit
voted remain Urban seats rural seats
newer colleagues most experienced
colleagues I'm really proud to have all
their support and I'm gonna as I said
we're in we're only halfway through this
thing I'm going to fight till the last
day with everything I've got because I'm
fighting for what I believe in
and if you do lose what happens do you
quit politics I say that simply because
of the Green Card thing
maybe some aspirations in America what
would happen next to Richard Cena
that's right questions
outside well Sandy you're not going to
get rid of me that easily all I can say
you know several years ago my members in
Richmond North Yorkshire did me the
enormous honor of selectomy as their
candidate and it's a great privilege to
carry on representing them for as long
as they'll have me okay so I asked this
question to Liz specifically in mind of
Martin Lewis's comments today Google
search is going up exponentially for how
will I pay my bills the telegraph
reporting that bills might go up to 5
000 pounds next January What
specifically and exactly are you going
to do to bring bills down and I'm not
talking about tax cuts in two years time
I'm talking about immediate relief and
help for families in addition to what
was announced in the budget yes I think
there are three different ways to think
about it the first is I think everyone
will need some help because the scale of
the challenge we're facing is just that
considerable and what I've said is very
quickly after taking office I will cut
VAT on energy bills and that will
provide an extra around 200 pounds of
support for all families and that will
well that will come on top of the
support that I announced as Chancellor
which is worth about 550 pounds for
everyone but then there are two other
groups of people who need extra help and
I talked about them earlier on it's the
most vulnerable in our society people
who don't have an easy way of increasing
their incomes don't have sufficient
savings to dip into and that's people on
very
and pensioners now no tax cut and Liz's
tax plan is not going to help those
groups of people right so scrapping the
Health and Social care area she wants to
do is worth 1 700 pounds to her on her
salary for someone working really hard
on the national living wage it's worth
just over a quid a week
and for someone who's a pensioner
without any earnings it's worth zero now
I want to provide direct support to
those groups of people
comparison
amazing sort of
reboot of furlough but four energy bills
and how much is it going to cost and
isn't that in turn going to be
inflationary no actually I've already
announced the transfer a mechanism to do
it and it's to provide direct financial
support to those groups of people
there'll be many pensioners here in the
audience tonight they're used to
receiving a winter fuel payment in the
winter and what I did as transfer to say
that we will provide additional payments
alongside that and we will need to
provide more than I thought previously
because the bills are worse and we need
to do the same for people on low incomes
now there are existing mechanisms to do
that that's what I said as Chancellor I
will do more as prime minister but if we
don't do that and this for everyone you
should just consider this point
if you support a plan that Liz is
suggesting which says she doesn't
believe in doing that doesn't believe in
providing direct financial support to
those groups of people and that's what
she said because she thinks her tax cut
is going to help them which it is not we
are gonna as a conservative government
leave millions of incredibly vulnerable
people at the risk of real destitution
now I think that is a moral failure
on Universal Credit when you're talking
about people who are on the state
pension but that it has been noted that
there's been a lack of help from you
from people who are sole Traders from
people who are running small and
medium-sized businesses if you're
running a business in this country and
you're looking at Rishi sunaka's chancer
and you're saying hang on a minute he's
part of my National Insurance
competition so I'm doubly taxed hang on
a minute
corporation tax what incentive do I have
to run a small business in this country
well well let's let's just look what
happened for all those small businesses
over the last couple of years the fact
that they're all still here today is
because of the things that I did over
the last two years
now one of the industries that I
passionately believe in when you talk
about small businesses is the
hospitality industry incredibly
important across our economy for the
number of people it employs actually
what are we doing this year we've cut
their business rates by 50 what are we
doing to help with their employment
costs cut their employment taxes by a
thousand pounds I announced that as
transfer in my last budget I'm also
helping them grow and I'm also helping
them grow and innovate actually one of
the things we have in this country which
we need to do a better job of is
supporting our small businesses to grow
and innovate use new technology and
that's why I created a program called
help to grow it provides them with many
mbas it provides them with software to
get online to make sure their business
can be even more profitable that's what
I'm doing for small businesses and you
talk about corporation tax 70 of UK
registered companies aren't going to see
any change in their corporation attacks
under my plan so they are going to be
protected from that
except 30 are incorporation taxes going
up and the Tory Manifesto said it
wouldn't look actually the Tory
Manifesto said it would say where it was
but we've had a pandemic
but let's talk about it yes corporation
tax is going to go up for the largest
businesses under my plan because I think
that's a reasonable and fair thing to do
in the circumstances but as I said
remember that 70 of companies won't see
an increase so small businesses are
protected the second thing you need to
know is the rate that it is going up to
is still the lowest in the G7 group of
countries that we compete with so it's
still lower than America France Italy
Germany Japan Canada let's broaden it
out to the 20 largest countries that we
compete with we'll still have the fourth
lowest rate so it's a very
internationally competitive rate but
I'll tell you what you need to most
importantly is that alongside that as I
said in my speech we are going to
radically cut taxes for businesses that
actually do the right things to grow our
economy that's businesses that invest
more businesses that innovate more
that's where our tax system isn't very
generous that's for how you drive growth
and productivity and create jobs in a
modern economy so I want to cut the
taxes on the things that work not just
sound good
[Applause]
[Music]
tax plan is simply wrong we've tried
we've tried it for 10 years and let me
tell you all business investment in this
country today is no greater than it was
a decade ago it hasn't worked the
experiment on corporation tax rate it
just simply hasn't worked if you want to
drive growth in a modern economy you
need businesses to invest business
investment in this country lags almost
every other Advanced economy why there
are many reasons but one of them is that
our tax treatment of it is not generous
enough and that's why we should focus on
tax cuts on the things that actually
will grow our economy and that's why
it's not inflationary if you cut taxes
for a business that is expanding its
Factory putting in a new production line
putting in robotics to increase its
productivity that's how you create more
products in a country that's how you
reduce inflation because they are proper
supply-side tax cuts what's confusing
people I think is you sort of making a
comment on the economy that you were in
charge of you know why didn't you
predict for instance the inflationary
nature responsible
why doesn't you do anything about that
we talk about Corporation yes and that's
why I want to change it I'm talking
about quantity some of the inflationary
measures that were put in place by the
bank of England have proved to be
disastrous that happened under your
watch so why are you now saying to
people I'm going to repair the economy
that has been damaged onto your watch
some would argue well I think when it
comes to the bank of England I think
maybe unlike what you just said and
unlike what Liz is saying I believe in
Bank of England Independence I think
it's an important thing I think it's a
very important thing and and I think
actually I'm very nervous about things I
hear elsewhere about people who seem to
think that from Liz's camp and her that
we should scrap Bank of England
Independence I think that would be a
massive mistake for our country and
international investors would really not
to look very funny on it at all
but what does the Bank of England does
things that seem to exacerbate the
problem rather than solve it the bank of
England has an independent mandate it is
set by the government and it's right and
it's it's right that we are tough in
making sure that we set the Mandate
right I did that but it's also worth
considering there has been a war on
Miller the reason that energy prices are
where they are in the first instance is
because we collectively decided rightly
to be robust in standing up to Russian
aggression that has led to higher energy
prices and and we have to acknowledge
that that is a big part of the reason
we're suffering from inflation
question came up quite a lot with
subscribers so I'm going to ask it if
you are this sort of Beacon of fiscal
discipline why did you veto chasing the
17 billion in foreign
[Applause]
minister resigning over what he
described was your Schoolboy tactics and
failing to grasp this well maybe he and
everyone else should read the report
that was just published the other week
but actually fortunately take the roads
or not and did it happen on the
treasury's watch it happens across the
entirety of government spending but what
you need to realize now because of the
mechanisms that I put in place the extra
teams that are out recovering the stuff
the arrests that are being made the new
laws that we pass the new agency of the
natural crime agency the estimated
forward fraud and furlough now is
actually estimated to be lower
then a typical government program and
that's something I set up in a matter of
weeks in the middle of a crisis so
actually I'm very proud of my record on
furlough and I'm proud that we have gone
after those who abuse it as a simple
matter of fairness it's wrong and we
will relentlessly pursue them so was the
treasury Minister wrong to resign yes he
was
[Applause]
former cabinet colleagues writing in the
telegraph saying that you resisted
attempts to cut brexit red tape uh that
you weren't committed to overhauling the
Northern Ireland protocol that you
blocked EU and Solomon C2 being changed
are you just a nominal brexite I mean a
greatest respect for all my colleagues
so I'm not going to get engaged in in
this but I would just gently point out
that neither quasi nor Simon Clark had
anything to do with solvency 2 and
financial services regulation that
wasn't done entirely by myself and John
Glenn and actually there is a bill that
is ready to introduce in Parliament as
soon as I become Prime Minister that
will radically change not to solvency
too but all of our financial services
regulations but what about this General
accusation and maybe it comes from the
right of the party but it's unfair that
you sort of
were taken hostage by the treasury a
treasury that we know is institutionally
opposed to brexit and constantly
obsessing about EU markets rather than
perhaps what the you know they were
public voted for yeah they they were
Camilla they were and you know what when
they said that I didn't listen to them I
voted for brexit but there was someone
else who held up their treasury
documents it wasn't me it was Liz truss
at the time okay so I'm very prepared to
confront the consensus actually on
corporation tax that's what we're doing
we're challenging consensus on EU
regulations who's come up with a policy
that actually takes advantage of brexit
in a radical way creating freeports
around the country I did that right
who's actually scrapping EU laws off the
statute book replacing them with a
British regulatory system in financial
services that's what I'm doing I'm
frustrated that I haven't seen that
degree of radicalism across government
that's what I want to change right so
that this idea that somehow I'm not
brexity enough I just find very puzzling
let's talk about your fellow brexit
chair Boris Johnson and to conclude
before we go to audience questions
um this privilege committee
investigation the goal posts have
changed a bit it was going to find out
whether he had deliberately misled
Parliament now it's just going to find
out if he misled do you support that or
do you think you should be reclused of
this investigation now so all I would
say is that the MPS on the committee are
the ones that make decisions and I fully
support them opinion on it well it's a
parliamentary actually I haven't
followed every Twist and Turn of it to
be honest because I've been busy being
out and about it's a parliamentary
process not a government process there's
a difference between them and I fully
respect the MPS that are on the
committee to make the right decisions I
personally believe very strongly in high
standards one of the things I would do
almost immediately as prime minister is
reinstate an independent advisor for
ministerial interests because everyone
needs to know that trust integrity and
decency belong at the heart of politics
and I will lead from the front
[Applause]
he hasn't returned my course
um right let's go to audience
presentations please put your hands
straight up
um let's take this lady in the blue on
the end here please
hi Rishi um I'm Penny and I'm the
national volunteer director for cpf
um how would you ensure that your policy
team engages with the cpf regular and
gets our feedback and also I was very um
interested here that you want every
child of a world-class education as a
speech and language therapist I'm
concerned that six to nine percent of
young offenders have undiagnosed speech
and language needs and also the reading
age between four and eight years of age
so how do we ensure it truly is a
world-class education system for
everybody including those with special
educational needs
thank you for the for the excellent
questions that has been a real privilege
to work with John Penrose and all your
colleagues while I was Chancellor and
thank you for all the ideas that you
sent so look quick quickly on on the
early years and that's actually the
point that I was going to make because
you talked about kids at a very early
age and you're right because if we now
look at all the negative outcomes we see
in society not just educationally but
all the other social ills that we see in
our older adults or late teens what's
clear is if we could have solved them at
a very early age we would have made an
enormous difference because actually if
you look at the inequality that exists
in our school system when children leave
school most of it was there when they
arrived so if we actually can tackle
things much earlier as you said focusing
on those very early years whether it's
four-year-olds five year olds we can
make an enormous difference and I made
some of that changes as Chancellor
starting to focus more of our resources
earlier on and it's something I think we
should keep doing now to your other
question now if you've got five minutes
you get I put it online on con home it's
called a contract with members and it's
what I want to do for the party because
we've talked a lot about what we'll do
for the country in this election but for
the party what I want to do is make sure
we actually regularly have a survey of
all of you it's a simple idea but we
don't do it currently and what I'd like
to do is make sure we have regular
surveys of your opinions but even better
than that there's no point just ask me
what you think what I want to what I've
committed to is not only will we have
those surveys but that those topics will
get discussed explicitly at political
cabinet so that all of you feel that
your participation and support of the
party is being recognized and discussed
at the highest levels so that we are all
on the same team and that's just one of
the few changes I want to make
I was going to ask an education because
it was the subject of that lady's
question obviously lots of being made
about your wife's family wealth and
things you do appreciate courses of
Winchester school boy that you were
afforded opportunities that have not
been offered to many many other children
in the UK what will you do about that
yes I have but and I'm I am absolutely
as you saw from the other stage I'm not
going to apologize for what my parents
did for me you must be joking
thank you
thank you
good evening good evening
um
so many of our Public Services just
don't seem to be working I know we've
been through a pandemic but I think the
fact of life from my perspective is when
we get to 2024 an election if all these
things and I'm not going to Rattle out
the whole list everything in HS or
ambulance or border force or today we
hear about police forces the list is
endless it's almost like nothing is
working and whoever is prime minister I
think will get booted out in 2024 unless
there are major improvements and I think
there will just be a fact of life
because people will say we need to
change because
the phrase used to be labor wasn't
working it was a great slogan the last
summer years back I think probably clear
starmer and Co will be able to
demonstrate that the Tory government is
not working because so many of these
things will still be below standard now
what are you going to fix it and I'm not
talking about high fluting ideas I'm
talking about the cold face where
delivery case yeah well sir your
question is absolutely right and look
there's so much we could talk about I'm
going to focus on one thing because it's
probably the most important and that's
the NHS right it's the NHS that is the
most used Public Service it's the thing
that people care about the most and
right now it's not working as well as it
should and I'll give you one very simple
idea of what I want to do you said a
cold face thing because we're going to
have to act boldly and radically if
we're going to change the dynamic here
if we're going to actually solve these
problems so I want to tackle the issue
that no one has bothered tackling for
years and that is the issue of missed
NHS appointments
because there are 15 million missed
appointments every year in the NHS not
just the GPS but at hospitals too and
that's wrong it's not valuing our
doctors properly but it's also more
importantly depriving people of care
that they urgently need making them wait
unnecessarily long so I've said I want
to get tough on this now lots of people
are going to say oh gosh will you can't
do that or it's too hard or you're being
too difficult tough on people no no
we've got to be radical and bond but if
we can solve that problem and it's not
about making money when I want to find
people it's about changing Behavior
because if we can get people to cancel
those appointments in advance even a few
of them we have created Millions more
NHS capacity to treat everyone who needs
it and treat them faster and none of us
have paid an extra Penny to do that so
there's a simple idea but if we can make
it work we'll make an enormous
difference to tackling the backlogs and
that is just one thing we can do but
that kind of radicalism and grit is what
I will bring to all the challenges that
we face you saw me do it in the pandemic
and I will do it as prime minister
across government can you just give us a
bit more detail on that are you saying
that you want to charge people for
appointments or find them if they miss
them and if you want to find them how
much are you thinking fines for missed
how much yeah I've said indicatively 10
pounds but the point here is not about
to it's not the point is not about to
making money the point is about for the
first time in our society changing the
culture where it shouldn't be acceptable
to miss appointments because you're
depriving people of care
the lady here and the wife
thank you Liz mentioned that she would
increase the defense budget by three
percent where do you sit supporting our
military yes well first of all let me
tell you about my track record I made
sure that we found an extra billion
pound to send to Ukraine just recently
from elsewhere across government
spending I made sure that everyone
prioritized differently we could take
the money and send it there because they
needed it it's the right thing to do I
was also the chancellor that alongside
the PM and the defense secretary oversaw
the largest increase in defense spending
since the end of the Cold War and we did
that in the middle of the pandemic
because the threats were rising and the
mod needed to have the security of
funding to deal with it so that's my
record now I'm not going to sit here and
tell you three percent because I don't
believe in arbitrary targets when it
comes to something as important as our
security
so what I will tell you is simple I will
invest whatever it takes to keep all of
you and our country safe because that is
the first duty of a prime minister and
it's certainly the first duty of a
conservative prime minister
[Applause]
um
hand up thank you
oh thank you um I'm just thinking about
um
your thoughts are issue in sense that
normally you don't raise tax
because if we're going to build that
Innovation economy of the future they're
not just good for jobs and growth but
also is doing life-changing things to
keep us all healthy it means that we
need to have a research base that is as
vibrant as it needs to be that's why we
are increasing our r d budget and why
big chunk of it is going to help it's
also why we need to take advantage of
our brexit freedoms that I talked about
when it comes to clinical trials I want
to make sure we do that differently so
we can get drugs through much faster
it's why I funded genomic sequencing
because we can now do screening at a far
earlier age to detect things it's why I
was in California in December meeting
companies that have new blood tests that
can detect all these Cancers and more
far faster than we've ever been able to
do it now that is a vision of the future
that I want to build in this country
because if we can get that right then
not only can we create the jobs and
prosperity we can keep people healthier
and safer for longer and I'm confident
that I can build the type of country
that will do exactly that but thank you
so much for what you do it's very
important
quick questions quick answers the lady
there with the spotty dress thank you
oh right yes quick questions quick
answers please thank you um Rishi my
question is more about you as a person
as opposed to policy I was very
undecided um and was abled as a district
councilor to go on a zoom call with Liz
and then a few days later a zoom call
with yourself
um I've come here tonight very much
still undecided but the key thing for me
is about you and Liz as a person now all
of us here tonight are extremely
um it's extremely important to us about
what our next prime minister does for
the country but it's extremely important
as to what we do or you do or Liz does
to win us a large majority in the next
general election now what that means is
you engaging with the electorate now
your passion from what I've seen tonight
and on the zoom calls your passion for
what you believe in could possibly be
portrayed as if somebody doesn't believe
the same thing as you do it could be
that they are wrong as opposed to take
them with with us so how will you engage
with the electorate to ensure that we
have a large majority at the next
general election right fine well that's
probably a good one to end on right so
sure so let's go back so look there's a
couple of things we're going to need to
do to support you and all our other
fantastic councilors win now I talked
about my contract with members actually
because that's an important part of it
one thing I want to do is raise far more
money than we've ever raised in our
party for one very particular purpose
and that is to put dedicated campaign
managers in all of our target areas
across the entire United Kingdom
because you deserve the support on the
ground but in terms of appealing to
people the people that we need to appeal
to people in swing seats everywhere
right they are not actually that
ideological right the people in the
middle are broadly comfortable with lots
of different things but what they want
is a government that works properly as a
gentleman was saying right and that is
what I will do the most powerful thing I
can do to appeal to those people for all
of us all those non-ideological swing
voters is what they want as a government
that works competently seriously with
decency and integrity at the heart of
everything it does that's the type of
change I'm going to bring that's the
type of government I'm going to lead and
that's how we're going to win the
election
questions
on the end here with the black jacket on
sir thank you be as quick as you can
both questioner and answer thank you
considering the age of everyone in here
and the conservatives totally screwed
the pensioners by stopping the uh the
triple lock what what are you going to
be doing about that
right sorry oh so it wasn't a question
about young people in the end right
sorry right so pensions of triple lock
is back it will be back in the next
freeing your pension will probably go up
by around 10 plus I would imagine
because that's where inflation will be
in the Autumn and it goes back to what I
was saying before because I do believe
that we should give people in retirement
dignity that's what a conservative
government does and that's why going
back to what we talked about right at
the beginning millions of pensioners
this Autumn winter are going to have an
extraordinarily tough time they don't
have the ability to go out and work more
hours they're already dipping into their
Savings in retirement and as I said then
and I'll say it again if we don't
provide direct support to millions of
vulnerable pensioners it will be a moral
failure of this party and the country
will never ever forgive us question
today because we've gone old let's go
young because this chat here seems to be
probably one of the youngest people in
the audience let's ask him final
question
we all continue to hear more and more
about the struggles with young people's
mental health this is particularly so as
we emerge from covert and the impact of
our well-being our social and our
academic development after nearly losing
two years due to lockdowns what are you
planning to do about the Mental Health
crisis affecting the younger generation
who are the future of this country
so thank you thank you for the question
look I I have two young girls there 9
11. I'll tell you one very specific
thing we have to do is that like many of
you in this room as parents and
grandparents you know my eldest one has
got her iPad she's about to start doing
things on her own and I am quite frankly
petrified about what she's gonna see and
see and read and be exposed to online
and it is clear that it is an enormous
enormous cause of mental health
challenges for young particularly girls
and so what I want to do is make sure
that we quickly pass a new law in
Parliament that we've been working on
that puts a much tighter obligation on
big digital companies to police the
online World in exactly the same way as
we were police the world that we walk
around in because there is nothing more
precious than our children and young
people's innocence they should be do not
they should not be denied that right and
I first and foremost not as prime
minister as a dad will make sure that we
do that
thank you
um there we have it ladies and gentlemen
very quick show of hands has anyone come
in here wanting to support one and
change their minds put your hand up if
you've changed your mind anyone switched
who who has decided put your hand up
who hasn't still decided put your hand
up
still a lot to play for with three weeks
ago thank you so much for joining us at
the telegraph Hastings have a very safe
journey back thank you to both uh
Michigan
[Applause]
Mrs Linda Paisley please make yourself
known to a steward in reception Mrs
Linda Paisley please make herself known
to a steward in reception
information